all right let's talk about whiny
celebrities we have uh Rolling Stone
Jack White quits Twitter calls Elon
musk's Trump reinstatement a-hole move
Trent rezner also quit like who cares
dude you guys aren't part of the
conversation you're welcome to part of
the conversation you are part of the
conversation so you cried and left so
what you weren't tweeting anyway yeah
he's like that Meme that's like the big
thumbs up yeah right we're gonna
continue with our conversation now thank
you he said this is straight up you
trying to help a fascist have a platform
so you can eventually get your tax
breaks
why are these people so
dumb yeah Elon paid the most amount of
taxes than any American citizen ever in
in history yeah so so why and who is he
accusing of being a fascist yeah who
exactly right Trump
hasn't tweeted it's been three days the
world hasn't ended like come on like
people take themselves way too seriously
and they're claiming that elon's forcing
him to follow Trump
that's ridiculous it's not true yeah
like At first I'm like you and on stuff
they're tweeting like Not only was Trump
reinstated but I found that I was
following him and I've never followed
him and I have to unfollow him and it's
like dude you you followed him come on
yeah we know he forgot who is who's this
guy Jack White The White Stripes
Seven Nation Army anything no no ring a
bell okay cool
people use a-hole as their number one
insult a-hole it's really cringy I don't
know why I don't know why that word is
part so perfect and the way they curse
it just feels like a 13 year old who has
a ghost before who's like trying to get
away with it I don't know Trent Reznor
left too and I'm just like
and yeah not very real right now no I
look you will not be but my favorite was
CBS News uh saying that they're going to
be leaving temporarily because of
security concerns and then coming back
and then still everyone's saying we
don't care we it's like it's okay
especially if you announce it you won't
have the willpower not to come back yeah
then they came back they came right back
just a few days afterwards a few hours
afterwards and it's like oh yeah we're
still looking we're monitoring the
situation like what what the thing is
none of these people can really leave
and that's why it's not the the last
kind of death croak of Twitter because
nothing on the planet has been able to
replicate the network effects that
Twitter has true I would be astonished
if it's just too valuable to too many
major stakeholders in the system just
recently you had Elon who by the way I
think he's maybe the first major Captain
of industry to mock the ADL since the
adl's Inception it's a first it's a
major thing it's incredible and he
continued it so Israel did a tweet and
Elon kind of mocked them too and but but
in a playful way saying look
um you know we need more people to tweet
we need more countries to tweet and so
if countries are tweeting
um you know it's just it's too valuable
it's it's not like there's this other
thing called what is it called like
Triceratops there there's some stupid
like left-wing version of Twitter that
they're trying to do
you can't you can't do that because of
the network of things actually actually
we're learning that Macedon is uh a
quite based actually they're uh
officially telling people
if you have a problem just block them
we're not going to ban them and they're
saying I saw this woman she said that
she got suspended on Mastodon because
she was calling out white people and
they were like yeah racism you're not
allowed that was that an actual thing or
just like an algorithmic no no someone
did it and they said that her posting
about this was like she got suspended
but people don't realize Mastodon it's
it's a uh they're different servers it's
so okay so it's the fetiverse Mastodon
is like I guess one note I'm not
entirely sure how it works I'm sure
people in chat probably know better but
basically when you sign up for it you
pick a server hosted by who knows and so
they warn you this is some random guy's
basement you don't know what he's doing
when you sign up for this to get off
Twitter he's got all your data your
password he's got everything and so
people are signing up and they're
thinking this is going to be better now
and there's a mod as a viral tweet where
he's like yo just block people I'm not
gonna we're not bad like just block them
even on Twitter weren't doing that
Twitter was Banning everybody so that's
turning out but it's fair enough but I
think the point stands Twitter is
something it's Unique its function as
the global Public Square is unique and
it has Network effects that
um are also unique and for that reason
um a lot of stakeholders are going to do
everything they can to prevent Elon from
going the direction he seems to be going
in he has a very difficult position he
needs to exercise
um a lot of caution he needs to approach
things with finesse and I would say so
far he's done about as well as we could
reasonably expect him to do given what
the stakes are and given what he's up
against yeah there's a couple hiccups
that he deserves to be criticized on
legitimately but you do make a good
point because where else could you see
the president of the ADL go after Elon
Musk and Elon Musk respond saying hey
stop defaming me where else where else
could you see Kanye West say shalom
right
this hive mind this this uh everybody's
reality Twitter is is amazing and the
people quitting it there's a reason
they're coming back all these people all
these actors hey I'm quitting Twitter
hey uh I'm still quitting Twitter but I
want to make one more post and another
post and this is this is again something
very similar to what we saw with uh Neil
Young with Spotify this is the same
thing we saw with all these celebrities
saying that they're going to be moving
to Canada a lot of these people are all
talk they're all bark no bite and we
have to understand these threats are
empty and they need to be called out as
ridiculous because Twitter is where it's
at right now it's fun it's entertaining
and it's where I'm at Saint Augustine
Lord make me Chase but not yet exactly
this is this is amazing when Kanye West
gets reinstated people are starting to
feel like I don't have to worry about
cancel culture anymore I don't have to
walk on eggshells so what does Kanye
tweet Shalom hilarious the ADL some some
guy he tweeted he's openly mocking us
now it's like uh-huh
so what like the problem is these people
were overly sensitive I don't think
Kanye West is as an anti-semite I think
he's probably got some wacky views I
think he's had some some silly things
but I think if he sat down with him and
talked to him you'd understand him right
it's he's not like this caricature of a
guy marching around with a hood and a
tiki torch or anything like that but
these people want to say that Libs of
tick tock for instance by simply
tweeting out I'm sorry retweeting videos
posted by people publicly she's
murdering them so there's this viral to
it I comment on it where they're like
you know uh uh Libs of tick tock has
murdered hundreds of LGBT people by
sharing these videos and it's like bro
the videos are public right literature
isn't doing anything if that's their
standard and people have to abide by
those kind of psychotic individuals
they're scared to speak out now Elon
comes in and says have fun guys and what
are we seeing spicy memes jokes trolling
and fun yeah comedy and you know what
Jack White well he doesn't like fun he's
as fun as bad so he has to leave okay
bye-bye we'll play your music dude I
don't care we'll we'll have we'll have
fun and and post spicy memes
bring back the meme Wars yeah
yeah it's sad and pathetic
um but yeah the whole thing about lives
of tick tock killing people that they
have this new term that a lot of these
kind of mid-wit mediocrities with
master's degrees are talking about
um called stochastic terrorism that's
right and uh it's it's really such a
joke concept but it effectively means
that you can't criticize anyone because
of the possibility that the criticism
would be out there in The Ether and some
crazy person might attack some kind of
Affiliated group and then of course
you're responsible
um so it's the latest of of many uh
censorship predicates that and then uh
the the woman behind the libs of tick
tock what's her name Chaya is that her
name she puts stochastic terrorists in
her bio and now I'm seeing these leftist
journalists be like she's openly
bragging about doing it and I'm like are
you kidding me do you really not
understand someone being facetious
making fun of you for calling them that
or are you intentionally just trying to
lie you know what man I'm glad Elon
bought Twitter because he he took over
the space and it is nuts to see this
like Luke mentioned telling that so the
president of ADL is like I can't believe
elon's doing this when he had a meeting
with us he promised us and then Elon
says stop defaming me like that's openly
mocking them but I guess Elon Musk is
the definition of Fu money just just
outright we'll see how far it goes but
so far I think he deserves credit
because there's so many people who you
think you would have Fu money but they
never they never use it in that fashion
and I think Elon is setting an excellent
example stepping into the actual Arena
Playing for Keeps and seeing where you
know seeing where things land
um so give a major credit and uh it's
only just begun so we'll see how it
unfolds I think Elon actually tweeted at
Trent Reznor too or tweeted about him or
something
I Don't Know Jack White posted on
Instagram some long diatribe that's not
worth reading that's not free speech or
what the poll decided or whatever
nonsense you're claiming to be this is
straight up you try to help a fascist
have a platform so you can eventually
get your tax breaks
like I don't think this guy knows
anything about tax law you know what I
mean no I mean it's the typical sort of
like maybe
105 IQ you know burned out idiot kind of
if that's high pseudo clever conspiracy
theory it's always like some dumb
Financial incentive that doesn't even
make sense if you actually know how
these things work there's a certain kind
of framework for this particular type of
accusation thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at
8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time